au mois de mars une pièce de théâtre
documentaire partira en tournée à
travers le Québec une oeuvre assez
inusitée parce que fait rare ici elle se
consacre entièrement à la réalité de la
production laitière à travers des
histoires de producteurs de
transformateurs la pièce ronde de lait
arrive à nous faire rire à nous faire
pleurer aussi parfois je me suis
entretenue avec son créateur Justin la
Ramée
[Musique]
c'est comme un pari en fait c'est de me
dire ça c'est intéressant
ça nous concerne tous j'y connais rien
je vais faire le chemin à place de tous
ceux qui se posent ces questions là
[Musique]
autant de détresse et de colère dans
notre plus important de production
agricole du Québec
[Musique]
Justin la Ramée Catherine Mercier on
s'est donné rendez-vous dans une étape
parce que devine que vous avez passé pas
mal de temps dans un lieu comme celui-ci
oui j'ai eu la chance de passer quand
même pas mal de temps pour un urbain
dans des belles étapes avec des belles
vaches mais justement comment on en
vient comme artiste qui est pas issu du
milieu agricole à se pencher pas
consacrer les cinq années de sa vie à la
production laitière ça a été quoi
l'élément déclencheur l'élément
déclencheur c'est
Ginette Lafleur c'est l'exposition
agriculturelle et ça commence avec la
détresse psychologique chez les
producteurs laitiers
en 2017 l'artiste et la chercheuse
s'intéressent aux enjeux de santé
mentale chez les agriculteurs il crée
une oeuvre basée sur les lettres écrites
par des agriculteurs qui se sont enlevés
la vie
ce sera le point de départ de Ron de
lait
qui est au cœur de l'agriculture pour
moi c'est les familles agricoles qui est
quelqu'un mette de larmes sur mes
travaux de recherche et les amen
ailleurs je trouve ça très intéressant
oublie pas de te mettre à leur place
oublie surtout pas de te mettre à leur
place il y avait tellement de choses il
y avait de la détresse psychologique qui
commence à sortir beaucoup et à bientôt
d'endettement et le Québec avait perdu
la moitié de ses fermes laitières au
cours des 20 dernières années j'essaie
d'aller rencontrer certains producteurs
et à ce moment-là je me dis ben il y a
quelque chose à raconter là je sais pas
exactement quoi encore donc ça m'a pris
5 ans pour le trouver raconter une seule
histoire entre guillemets donc celle
dans ce cas là de la perte des fermes au
Québec ça fait moyenne en fait
disparaître tranquillement pas vite au
Québec
[Musique]
dans cette pièce là c'est du théâtre
documentaire
on a l'impression que vous allez de
découverte en découverte qu'est-ce qui
vous a le plus étonné je ne savais pas
qu'une vache devait accoucher chaque
année pour donner du lait ça a été c'est
des choses réellement que je savais pas
que j'apprends je savais pas qu'on
mangeait de la vache j'avais aucune idée
qu'on mangeait de la vache dans ma tête
on mangeait du bœuf on mangeait pas de
la vache donc c'est des vraiment des
choses que c'est à dire que les vaches à
la fin de leur vie productive elle s'en
vont comme vache de réforme et vont être
transformés en steak haché d'ailleurs ce
mot là j'entendais les vaches de réforme
je pensais que c'était des vaches
méchantes vaches qui semblent se faire
rééduquer mais bon non c'est des vaches
qui vont à l'abattoir donc plein de
choses comme ça pour cette naïve tu es
là à être beaucoup à créer un vrai lien
en fait avec les gens du milieu je me
prends pas je prends pas une posture
différente de celle que j'ai prise au
départ qui est celle de quelqu'un qui
connaît pas ça mais qui veut mieux
consommer je ne comprends pas pourquoi
tous les petits abat toirs ou presque
confirmés donc on a 400 000 vaches de
réforme au Québec et on doit les envoyer
se faire abattre chez Cargill dans le
sud de l'Ontario ou majoritairement
Pennsylvanie ce qui veut dire qu'au
Québec on a la promesse avec le plus de
vache mais aucune idée du boeuf qu'on
achète à l'épicerie et pour moi ça ça
fait pas de sens
au cours de sa recherche les pierres de
l'édifice laitier sont retournés une à
une dont celle de la gestion de l'offre
le Canada est l'un des derniers endroits
dans le monde où la production laitière
est planifiée en fonction de la demande
de la population le système vise à
éviter les surplus et à offrir un prix
décent aux agriculteurs
mais plusieurs récentes entendent de
libre-échange sont venus créer des
brèches dans la gestion de l'offre on
doit vraiment se poser collectivement la
question de ce qu'on veut réellement
comme comme agriculture au Québec c'est
quelque chose qui nous appartient tous
c'est des modèles agricoles qu'on s'est
construit sur lesquels on se nourrit
donc on est collectivement responsable
de cette réflexion là
il y a une outil que je n'ai pas au
départ quand je faisais le spectacle à
Québec qui est la vache bleue pour
parler en fait de la consommation locale
de
s'assurer que dans le produit laitier
qu'on le yogourd parce que le lait vient
aujourd'hui de consommation vient
toujours ici on n'a pas besoin de le
marquer mais tout ce qui est produit
laitiers si on voit la vachement
tout ce qui arrive à ce moment-là on est
certain qu'il y a pas d'ingrédients les
pieds de l'étranger les États-Unis de la
Nouvelle-Zélande de l'osté peu importe
qui rentre dans la confection du produit
déjà ça déjà ça on fait un bout de
chemin ça donne un levier au
consommateur pour faire un choix éclairé
parce que sinon c'est un peu déprimant
en effet non mais c'est parce que c'est
déprimant parce que le constat est
difficile on va continuer à perdre les
films sur le gros lot nous disait Marcel
grelot l'ex-président de de l'UPR qui
nous a reçu avec beaucoup d'élégance à
sa ferme il disait que selon lui c'était
inéluctable la perte de fermeture
inéluctable et ça ça va avoir des
incidences énormes sur l'occupation du
territoire au Québec c'est sûr
[Musique]
il y a quelqu'un dans votre spectacle
qui mentionne les gens qui a des fermes
laitières en Gaspésie ou en habit de
tibi ça les intéresse pas vraiment mais
pourquoi on devrait s'intéresser ou se
préoccuper du fait qu'il y ait des
fermes sur le territoire partout c'est
ferme là ils font vivre la quincaillerie
du coin la machinerie font vivre des
villages etc donc ce n'est pas juste je
veux tout du lait ou je veux pas du lait
c'est vraiment une question de qu'est-ce
qu'on veut comment on veut voir le
Québec comment on peut l'occuper comment
on veut développer aussi les
spécificités des régions il y a des
projets incroyables à faire avec le
terroir qu'on a il faut juste avoir le
courage politique on voit les ravages
que ça fait aux États-Unis d'ailleurs où
est-ce que les femmes sont devenus de
plus en plus grosses est-ce que c'est ce
qu'on veut il y a 1000 défis dans
l'industrie des tiers mais ce qu'il faut
pas oublier c'est que c'est notre plus
important de production agricole donc ce
n'est pas
anecdotique il faut pas le traiter comme
si cela l'était en fait
[Musique]
l'élément déclencheur c'est la détresse
psychologique mais ensuite il y a
toujours le thème du bien-être animal
qui revient beaucoup de gens préfèrent
qu'on en parle pas ça met tout le monde
mal à l'aise mais c'est essentiel exact
dans la pièce en fait c'est une des
choses dramatiques dont je suis le plus
fier c'est que je savais pas comment
l'aborder parce que je savais que ça
allait il faut pas tomber dans le point
de vue moral ne pas en parler devenait
une posture absolument impossible à
soutenir non plus
quand on peut l'envoyer à laquelle
c'est pas là que j'ai de l'argent ces
dernières fois j'ai un beau veau le 100
livres en pleine santé j'ai eu 6 pièces
et 37 pour mon beau petit croire
avant même de se rendre compte
[Musique]
c'est la présidente du conseil
d'administration de l'Association
végétarienne de Montréal donc Florence
Candy a accepté d'entrer à la limite
comme personnage donc elles viennent
parler tout le long du spectacle mais je
suis toujours en train de la repousser
en disant oui oui c'est ton tour plus
tard c'est un petit peu plus tard on va
se parler oui ça sera pas long j'ai fait
du gélules en fait notre déni collectif
le fait que c'est difficile d'entendre
parler de ces choses-là mais qui il faut
en parler et je pense que on en parle de
mieux en mieux
[Musique]
l'enquête commence avec la détresse
psychologique chez les producteur
laitiers et se termine avec la détresse
du consommateur d'un père de père en
famille de deux jeunes enfants qui ne
sait plus où se positionner quant à sa
consommation à la fois de produits
laitiers mais agricoles ou complet
pourquoi il se sent si loin d'une
certaine façon des agriculteurs qui le
nourrissent à tous les jours et comment
faire pour rapprocher tout ça cette
rencontre là dans ces des fois c'est
deux polarités là c'est sûr qu'un
terrain d'entente puis
j'espère que Rome delay permet au moins
de faire un pont entre les deux et de de
reconnecter ces deux univers là
[Musique]